hey guys how's it going i'm so excited
because a lot of you guys
have been aiding in sort of this
unboxing because i tweeted a while ago
this was
maybe months and months ago about what
gaming laptop should i get because i
travel a lot and the only thing that i
really want to do
is to be able to play video games on the
go and lugging around
a pc tower is not an option and
sometimes it gets really difficult to
travel with my xbox or playstation or
any of that kind of stuff
so i decided that a gaming laptop was
really what i needed
and you guys gave me so many suggestions
that it was so overwhelming i ended up
getting in contact with intel who you
guys know i've worked with so many times
before and they're so fantastic
and i was like listen i've got all of
these suggestions for gaming laptops
what do you think i should get here it
is
let's open it because i can't wait any
longer
i'm going to play minecraft so hard on
this laptop
okay let's open you up
i need to get to the insides
this is like a first date
is anything important this looks
important
semi-important
you look beautiful holy
moly i'm going to be able
to fly to the moon and back oh you look
so
nice ready to talk to cortana
i've never had a big laptop before oh
wow
that's big you're big alright it looks
like i'm gonna have to plug you
alrighty let's see what we've got this
is
this great let's plug you in
i'll start you up has the intel core i7
in it we've also got the geforce
gtx 960. oh this is gonna be a whole
process
also to go along with it i got a few
accessories as well
if you're gaming you're gonna need a
good gaming mouse and a mouse pad
well friends this is what we've got here
this is the razer mamba tournament
edition
mouse and i've already configured it to
be
pink this is the razer firefly
mouse pad also usb powered and you can
change
all of these lights in the configuration
settings in the razer app
you can make these do pretty much
whatever you want i'm not sure if you
can even see because it's too bright let
me
let me shut off the lights and show you
i mean would you look at that
would you look at that
well that's it for this video i'm gonna
get to setting up this computer so i can
actually get to play with it
and i will see you guys later hope you
enjoyed the video i'll see you later bye
swap that out put this one on and then
i'm gonna try
this little rode microphone it's one of
the mini ones so it's a little bit
smaller
this is gonna be a great vlog it's gonna
be like we're shooting a feature film at
the cheesecake factory on